[Musique]
malbrouck s'en va-t-en guerre à me
rendormir entends me rend très normal
bruce s'en va-t-en guerre voir qu'est ce
que c'est casimir veux tu s'il te plus
cessé de chanter ça me fait gonfler les
oreilles nos cinq ans reviendra il
reviendra à pâques en iran pour me rends
ton mir hossein
il reviendra à pattes un mois la
pérennité
casimir dis-moi casimir qui ce monsieur
malroux dont tu parle tout le temps je
ne le connais pas léonard tu es un
ignorant
et quand est-ce qu'il viendra monsieur
malbrouck 1
tu pourras me le présenter peut-être tu
sais les amis de mes amis sont mes amis
mais il n'existe pas c'est le héros
d'une vieille chanson française que que
je lis m'a apprise ont très bien très
bien très ignorants comme tu es tu ne
s'est peut-être pas non plus pourquoi je
chante cette chanson
1 et bien c'est parce que c'est bientôt
pâques un et je suppose que tu ne sais
pas non plus ce qu'est paca bon et bien
rac1 c'est le jour où les cloches
viennent au dessus de l'île et pondent
des oeufs dans tout le jardin
non non tu es fou casimir ce ne sont pas
les cloches qui pondent des oeufs
ce sont les poules mais non écoute je
sais bien placé pour le savoir enfin
j'adore les oeufs mais j'adore encore
plus les poules coûtant habituellement
peut-être mais le jour de pâques ce sont
les cloches et les jeunes se casse pas
en tendant à non non non parce que ce
jour-là ce jour là bas ils doivent être
exceptionnellement solide à des les
cloches font très attention de laisser
tomber les eaux délicatement dans les
buissons en casimir tu es sûr tu ne
manques pas de moi ah non absolument pas
mais alors il faut vite regarder si les
clans j'arrive
oui des piscines ou peut-être son
tout près d'ici parler manger quoi
vachement vite
c'est une très bonne idée quoi penser
sont peut-être déjà là à temps alors on
regarde bien fait attention aux nuages
qui risque de les cacher pour l'instant
je ne vois rien attends je vais voir là
bas alors aulas la houlala
oulala toi qu'est-ce qui vient kaseya
une énorme claque au vent vient sans
doute pour te voir un petit monstre roma
dont 11 à pois bleus quoi ouais ma maman
celle futé exactement jeu dans la série
call bon après midi
hall a vendu moselle futé casimir leone
avant peut-être et bonjour ma grosses
cloches en chocolat des îles grosses
cloches en chocolat au lait un homme
entre toi vous vont m'en voulez pas mal
moins futés non voyons léonard c'est
bien vrai pourquoi m'appelle q tu as
grosses cloches en chocolat désir
parce que casimir m'a dit que les
cloches volante allait faire une escale
ici spécialement dans l'île et nous sont
laisserai tomber des oeufs dans les
buissons
est ce que c'est vraiment moi c'est à
peu prés salés anna mais sais-tu d'où
vient cette coutume des oeufs de pâques
ah non je trouve que c'est une très
bonne habitude mais c'est tout ce que je
sais de son est bien autrefois pendant
le carême qui était d'une durée de 40
jours avant pâques
on n'avait pas la permission de manger
des canons arrive le coup tu
alors on les mettait de côté on les
faisait cuire et puis on les payait en
rouge en verre en bleu
et puis le jour de pâques dans chaque
famille on organisait une distribution
de décorer et maintenant et maintenant
que ce sont les cloches qui les
apportent et les enfants organisent
partout dans les villes dans les maisons
dans les jardins des grandes chasses aux
oeufs parce que naturellement les clans
junte leur jeu par les fenêtres et les
intérêts dans les salons elle
naturellement et et naturellement il
devrait y avoir une planche qui êtes un
grand panier 2 dans ma main ici ah oui
les renards mais ceci laisse le
couvercle de ta malviennes ouvert et je
ne vous tombe pas sur le tâte jeannerat
alors vraiment ces cloches de pâques
sont très intelligent très intelligent
bonjour ma chère aide mais on se porte
notre botaniste très très bien monsieur
du snav serono la main que malaxer les
vous lâche est raide mais bien c'est une
préparation spéciale pour 1,9 que
j'aurais pas pour casimir de la crème de
marrons de la choucroute du sucre des
primes en rouge et un peu de farine à
vous donner beaucoup de mal dans ce gros
balourd
enfin je vous laisse à votre cuisine à
plus tard en mais non mais non monsieur
du sahb revenus oui oui vous n'êtes pas
censé ignorer que c'est bientôt pâques
oui je n'ignore pas évidemment bien
alors j'ai l'intention d'organiser une
grande chasse aux oeufs pour léonard
casimir et tous les enfants à les
enfants sont ravis
c'est très bien ma chère et demi oui
alors soyez gentil monsieur du stop
donnez moi un coup de main parce que
j'aurais pas ton tout finir ah bon mais
je n'y comprends absolument rien on ne
veut pas que vous avez mais si mais si
tu tenais asseyez-vous là vous allez au
lit c'est très simple que doit les peurs
voilà vous prenez tout c'est eux
oui voilà voilà le point sur wii les
couleurs oui voilà
et je peins et vous ping et vous croyez
que ce n'est pas déshonorant pour un
artiste peintre de faire ce travail là
mais non mais non pas du tout et quand
vous aurez terminé vous les placerait
dans ces petits ni la hâte que vous
voyez est bien aussi que ne remplit pas
les cacher
et puis en plus après toutes les colères
que vous avez eue contre quasiment vous
lui devez bien ça jamais de colas contre
quasiment ma chère anne mais j'ai
seulement essayé de lui faire comprendre
l'insistance un petit peu je lave ou de
ne pas prendre mes oeuvres d'art pour
pour des petits fous c'est bien pour une
fois vous serez ravis qu'ils les mangent
des oeuvres la voilà on ça ira comme ça
voilà voilà vous avez terminé monsieur
dû se terminer bien n'oubliez pas de
conserver quelques eu de coup de frais
pour léonard et il ne les aime qu'au
naturel
saleh elles sont passées léonard ouais
tu vas à l'avant du jardin et tu
fouilles de kiosques et moi je vais sur
la gauche vers la cage à poules et le
banc enfin d'accord on y va martin ya
j'en ai déjà un os aussi à wassit
attention venez m'aider les enfants hop
encore un an encore en ici 3 4 oh oh
qu'il est gros celui là on l'a
elle devait être énorme c'est aux
cloches
voilà un dieu regardez un art
j'en ai déjà si ça et vous les enfants
vous en avez trouvé beaucoup de voix
qu'il ressemble à aucune autre
ah non non léonard celui ci est pour moi
d'ailleurs il y à mon nom dessus c'est
bon bon bon rang mais moi enfin j'aurais
préféré trouver une poule c'est encore
meilleur
léonard tu m'avais promis de ne plus
jamais mangé de poule à d'ailleurs qu'il
ya une superbe collection d'oeuvres à
gober pendant ce temps là je vais manger
le mien est gelée préparés spécialement
pour toi mon gars ont vraiment leur tous
les deux vous êtes formidables épatant
époustouflant oui mais vous ne devriez
pas vous en tenir là ah bon que nous de
dire eh bien pendant que nous mangeons
nozer mademoiselle futaie pour avoir
préparé un second comme celui ci aurait
vous vous pourriez nous chanter une
chanson si l'occasion et bien écoute
casimir je veux étonner
j'accepte musique comme d'hab
[Musique]
m
j'ai chassé le lézard vert pendant trois
jours au congo j'ai jouer à saute
pingouins avec un chef eskimos je suis
très snob
chaque jour je colle un gros oeuf
d'autruche à mon petit déjeuner j'ai
chanté un opéra dans la rue attend
bordeaux trouver les trésors zaka dans
un musée du pétrole
les gens s'arrachent mais autographes on
m'a reconnu dans un heureusement
quartier jeu
[Musique]
suis un champion dé la sculpture
run jeu
[Musique]
fait lécher devrait en peinture je suis
le plus grand le plus beau le plus fort
je connais le fils du frère de la
belle-soeur de marquis c'est un homme de
qualité la preuve c'est qu'il me l'a dit
il très snob
comme moi il colle un gros atout truchat
son petit déjeuner il sait parler c'est
très snob avec un accent anglais
moi j'y arrive
mieux avec la sam à payer
j'ai lu talent c'est évident de toute ma
rue je suis la célébrité jeu
suis un champion de la sculpture
pour m
je
fait les chefs-d'oeuvre de peinture je
suis le plus grand le plus beau le plus
fort mais il m'arrive quelquefois
devrait rentrer un peu fou je m'appelle
monsieur durand et j'ai les mêmes goûts
que
jeanne c'est plus moi alors je colle
un petit oeuf de poule qui me rend tous
des primaires
matin quand je m'éveille j'oublie mon
rêve et c'est bien je vois ma canne mon
chapeau et mon costume italien ch
redevient ce nom alors je colle un gros
oeuf d'autruche à mon petit des jeux
o o 1 pouces elle
[Musique]